this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below more on them in
just a bit
on february 8th 1983 the world of sports
was left dismayed and bewildered when
one of its greatest champions sure was
kidnapped by a group of masked men armed
with machine guns from his farm in
ireland a ransom demand soon followed
the kidnapping but before anyone could
pay up the criminals cut off all
communications it has long been
speculated that shergar resisted his
captors and was killed during the
struggle once the criminals lost their
meal ticket they tried to erase all
signs of what had happened and
completely distanced themselves from the
botched kidnapping we say speculated
because the remains of shergar were
never found and the identities of his
killers were never discovered the true
fate of this championship race remains a
mystery to this day and oh yeah in case
we forgot to mention it sugar was a
horse
let's start off with the elephant in the
room so to speak subject for today was
not a human he was a horse but not just
any horse he was a thoroughbred racer
widely considered one of the best of all
time and who still holds the record for
the biggest winning margin at the epson
derby arguably the most prestigious
horse race in british sugar was born or
fooled to use the correct term on march
the 3rd 1978 at the shasoon stud farm in
county kildare ireland the owner of the
stard was agar khan iv the islamic
leader and business magnate like us we
are going to assume that most of you
haven't done a lot of horse breeding in
your lifetime so we're going to keep you
up to date with all the fancy pants
jargon physically sherga was described
as having a bay color that's a reddish
brown with a black mane and tail with
white socks on his legs and a white
stripe on his face called a blaze when
it comes to racehorses their pedigree is
very important so we can actually trace
shergar's lineage with a lot more
accuracy than a lot of human subjects
that we've covered here on biographics
both of his parents were champion racers
his mom who is called a damn was
charming while his father also known as
a sar was called great nephew even as a
fall shergar showed great promise so he
was sent to england for training when he
became a yearling aka a young horse
between one and two years of age once he
passed the age of two he became a cult
unless he was castrated in which case he
would have been a gelding shurgar's
trainer was sir michael stout one of the
best in the business and he recalled
that the horse displayed a gentle
temperament and he responded well to
training in 1980 it was time for sure to
make his training debut it was september
and the race was the 1600 meter chris
plate newberry for a jockey aeger khan
spared no expense he hired leslie pigott
one of the most successful riders in the
country it was a dominating debut for
sugar as the horse won the race by two
and a half lengths
length being a common unit of distance
used in racing defined as the average
length of a horse from nose to tail or
approximately two and a half meters
right off the bat everybody was
impressed with sherida's performance and
there was an immediate feeling that they
had something special on their hands the
wars only had one more race in 1980 the
1600 futurity stakes at doncaster again
scherger performed well but he actually
came in second this time even so the
team still accomplished its goals of
giving sherga some valuable experience
and creating a lot of positive buzz
around him now it was time to give him a
little rest and start preparing for the
next season where sherga would take the
racing world by storm
with the start of a new year came the
start of a new racing season and shergo
was already branded as the one to watch
surprised to say that he did not
disappoint his first race was the 2000
meter guardian classic trial in april
and he took home first place ridden by a
new jockey named walter swinburne this
was quickly followed by another victory
the following month at the 2400 metre
chester vase showing to the world that
sure had stamina and consistency as well
not just speed but then came the race
that propelled sugar into super stardom
the derby stakes also known as the
absent darby one of the most important
races in the world shanghai not only won
the race but he dominated it finishing
by 10 lengths ahead of second place a
record in the derby's 240 year history
that still stands today and just like
that shergar became the most valuable
horse in the world worth an estimated 15
to 16 million dollars which is around 45
to 48 million dollars today and he
showed no signs of slowing down because
less than a month after coming in first
in england's most prestigious race he
traveled to ireland where he did the
same thing by winning the irish derby
then after that came the king george one
of england's premier horse races all of
this was building up to shergar
competing in the pre-de art triumph in
france simply known as the arc which is
widely regarded as the most esteemed
race in all of europe it's over to
horses of all ages and would have been
the perfect way to cap off what up to
that point had been one of the greatest
and most profitable seasons in horse
racing history however that race was
still two and a half months away
following the king george and xiang's
team decided that it was too long to
wait so they entered him into another
race in early september to keep up his
momentum it was the same lego stakes in
doncaster and a length of 2800 meters it
was the longest race that sure had ever
competed in and it ended in a massive
disappointment like most of his races
the horse stayed close to the front
runners for most of the event in all
other ones however scherger would always
overtake on the final straight and win
the race this time he simply didn't and
he ended in a decidedly mediocre fourth
place he finished a total of eleven and
a half lengths behind the winner nobody
was really sure what had happened
extensive tests showed that cho was not
injured or in poor health but that
fourth place scared his team enough that
not only did they pull him out of the
ark but they retired him completely
putting an end to shoghar's racing
career after only eight competitions not
that his owner was too broken up over
the decision since it already made back
his investment several times over
following shergar's commanding victory
at the epson derby edgar khan received
multiple offers to sell his prized horse
instead though he decided to syndicate
shergar selling 40 shares worth about
hundred thousand dollars each in 1982
money he himself kept six shares and
sold the rest to individual bars as far
as show was concerned he was retired to
stud at bali manny farm in new bridge
county kildare island he had put in the
work and was now supposed to reap the
benefits of a life of leisure not to
mention that he was going to get freaky
with dozens of mares in order to sire
the next generation of champions or at
least that's what everyone hoped would
happen but that's not exactly how things
played out alright we'll get back to
today's video in just a second but first
here's a word from our longtime friends
over at squarespace this is the age of
creation everyone is out there on the
internet not just consuming stuff
anymore they are
making it you've either got a great idea
for a website yourself or you probably
know someone who does and when it's time
to move that project from your head to
the screen in front of you that's where
squarespace comes in it's the perfect
web tool to help you fashion the
internet into whatever you like maybe
the hands on time you got lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly
your website should look like if so
great squarespace offers you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about or maybe you
just need something functional something
that works with minimal thought so you
can stay focused on the content and not
just the coat and paint just use one of
their quick beautiful templates to make
a website that's both fresh and simple
and once you're done setting up the
website locking in the name maybe
playing with some of the colors there
are so many extra features that
squarespace provides so your website can
thrive email campaigns patronage portals
social integrations member only areas
analytics commercial options 27 customer
support everything you ever want in one
place so when you're ready to get
started on the next web project of yours
big or small it evolves a website do
squarespace go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch your new site go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or a domain
and let's get back into it
at first things went pretty well for the
retired chap sharoghah got to enjoy one
full rutting season during which he bred
or covered to use the correct lingo over
40 mares and produced 35 offspring none
of them however ended up holding a
candle to dear old dad and jaragar's
only foul that achieved some notable
racing success was a stallion named
ulsal who won the irish saint laga among
a few other races nobody knew that yet
of course so shagger's services were
still very much in demand and his 1983
stud season was fully booked with even
more mares than his first but then on
february 8 1983 the unthinkable happened
it was around 8 30 p.m and the head
groom balamani stud jim fitzgerald had
retired for the day was resting
alongside his wife and five children in
his home located on the stable grounds
when he heard a loud knock at the door
his son bernard answered the door and
was greeted by two masked men waving
around machine guns immediately it
became clear what they were there for
even without a single word being spoken
after all there was only one thing of
real value at the farm shurga as a few
other gunmen made their way into the
house one of the original two collected
fitzgerald's entire family and locked
them inside a room while the other
demanded that the groom take him to
sugar fitzgerald was hardly in a
position to negotiate he was outmanned
out gunned and the criminals held his
family at gunpoint so he did what he was
told and he went to collect the horse
when he and sugar were outside the
gunman he was with took out a
walkie-talkie and had a horse trailer
pull up the groom couldn't tell exactly
how many criminals there were but he
guessed it was around half a dozen both
horse and caretaker quietly obeyed
scherger went inside the trailer while
fitzgerald put on a blindfold and was
taken inside another car the two
vehicles departed and just like that the
horse napping was complete the cars
drove around for hours finally they
stopped on some dusty road in the middle
of nowhere and let fitzgerald out he was
warned not to contact the police
otherwise he and his family would be
killed they told him the ransom demand
to get sugar back was 2 million pounds
about 2.6 million dollars and gave him
the code king neptune to confirm their
identities later when they would call as
the cause drove off fitzgerald was left
wandering the irish countryside in the
darkness until he stumbled upon the town
of killcock and found a phone the threat
against his family was still fresh in
his mind so the groom did not alert the
police but made the first call to his
brother who came and picked him up in a
car and drove him back to the stables
once fitzgerald was sure that his family
were safe he called his boss stud
manager gus lane drion who then tried to
read jayukah in switzerland a few other
people including shaggy's veterinarian a
finance minister and an official with
the irish thoroughbred breeding
association were all apprised of what
had happened and none of them were
really sure how to proceed high profile
whole snappings were quite rare the last
one had occurred in 1977 when a mare
named fran faloush was stolen from her
paddock in kentucky eventually one of
them we don't know who contacted the
police and told them what happened but
by then the gunman had at least a six
hour head start
[Music]
the next day local police started the
search for sureguard but the kidnappers
had picked their opportunity very
carefully a big horse sale was taking
place in the area that day so there were
a sea of horses and trailers everywhere
the criminals could have probably ridden
sugar down the street without anyone
noticing them plus from the very
beginning the investigation was hampered
by the fact that multiple law
enforcement agencies got involved and
they didn't play very nicely with each
other it soon became evident that they
had no choice but to wait for the ransom
call it came the next evening kiss
adrian the ballet money manager answered
the call and following instructions from
the garda the irish police service he
played dumb and stalled the time to keep
the kidnappers on the line for 90
seconds in order to trace the call or it
seems like the criminals had seen the
same police movies as the rest of us and
were wise to the trick they hung out the
phone and called back several times to
prevent a trace occasionally the
conversation turned to a surreal comedy
sketch as dreel a frenchman struggled to
understand the caller's thick irish
accent while the man on the other end
had the same problem with his french
accent eventually the kidnappers got fed
up with dreon and demanded to speak with
agar khan or someone in his inner circle
but they were all abroad at the same
time an even stranger episode was
happening inside the bbc newsroom in
belfast as they also received a call
from someone reporting to be the
abductors the anonymous caller had a
very bizarre and specific demand
insisting that he would only deal with
three people lord oaksie peter camplin
and derrick thomas all three of them
horse racing journalists and pundits
from london by that point the whole
world knew about the kidnapping of
shergar so unsurprisingly the
journalists jumped at the opportunity to
be part of the hottest story of the year
before you knew it the three of them had
a camera crew had flown to belfast and
checked in at the europa hotel as per
the caller's instructions there another
call came through and the man instructed
them to get rid of all the media that
was following them around like a lost
puppy and go to a secluded farm 30 miles
from belfast with a little help from the
police the three pundits managed to lose
the local press by sneaking through the
kitchen and out the service entrance
into a waiting vehicle they then sped
off not really knowing where they were
supposed to go unsurprisingly they got
lost and were driving in the remote area
around belfast when they got stopped by
a group of five guys wearing ballot
clothes and wielding machine guns first
impressions suggested that this was the
same group of guys who kidnapped sure
but first impressions were deceiving
because they were actually the police
they realized that the london boys would
probably get lost in the woods so they
came to the rescue eventually everyone
reached the farmhouse so there was
nothing else to do but wait for the call
thompson would do the talking he knew
the score keep them on the line for 90
seconds when the first call came through
the kidnapper demanded an initial
payment of 40 000 pounds while the
journalist insisted on proof that sherga
was still alive they went back and forth
like this over the course of about eight
to ten calls all of them ending around
the 80 to 85 second mark then it seemed
like they finally struck gold with the
last one after eight hours of
negotiations it was one in the morning
but thompson managed to keep his
conversation partner on the line for 95
seconds he turned around with a look of
hope and expectation at the police
officer next to him only to be told i'm
sorry mr thompson but the man who traces
the calls was off shift at midnight so
that was it the angle of the
investigation and thompson's involvement
turned into a resounding dud but what
was all that malarkey about 40 000
pounds fitzgerald's kidnappers told them
they wanted 2 million pounds 40 000
pounds was a drop in the bucket compared
to what sugar was worth nowadays most
people see this as a bit of a wild goose
chase but the question is who was behind
it was it just some random guy who got
bored and thought he'd try as a luck or
was it the same people who actually
kidnapped sugar working a second angle
to confuse and preoccupy the police
[Music]
[Applause]
running parallel to the strange episode
involving the london journalists with
the negotiations between khan and the
man who definitely kidnapped sure but
almost immediately it became pretty
clear that the criminals did not take
into account the fact that edgar khan
could not make unilateral decisions
involving sherga since he was just one
of 36 owners this made negotiations drag
on for several days as there was heavy
disagreement within the syndicate
regarding the best way to proceed some
wanted to pay the money thinking it
would still be a small sum compared to
the profits sure could bring over the
years or even decades of breeding others
steadfastly refused fearing that if they
paid up they might as well paint a giant
red target on the back of every other
horse in the world sure others had been
kidnapped before but none of them were
as valuable or as famous as sherga so if
they caved into ransom demands they were
declaring open season on other champion
breeders ultimately though the syndicate
did not have to reach a decision because
the kidnappers broke off contact before
that could happen after a few days of
negotiations the owners decided not to
proceed any further unless they obtained
some evidence that chaga was still alive
on february 12th four days after the
kidnapping one of the abductors left
evidence at the rostenary hotel near
dublin in the form of a package
containing polaroids of the horse
including some that displayed a
newspaper from the previous day in the
background for some reason the pictures
were all close-ups of sharga's head this
did not reassure the shareholders if
anything it made them more suspicious
the horse in the polaroids was
definitely sugar but why would the
kidnappers avoid showing the entire
animal that same night the criminals
called again with the same demands but
the syndicate rebuffed them saying that
the pictures were not proof enough of
sherga's status clearly this struck a
nerve because the caller said well if
you're not satisfied that's it and the
line went dead and that really was it
nobody ever heard from the kidnappers or
sherga ever again the irish police led
by chief superintendent jim murphy
continued the investigation of course
but they never made any serious headway
and was skewered by the press murphy
received the brunt of the mockery often
being compared to inspector clouseau or
the keystone cops for the media the
whole thing was like an all you can eat
buffet and they gorged on every juicy
little tidbit they uncovered the crazier
the better one story reported that the
police turned to psychics and
clairvoyance for help another claimed
that scherger was alive and well at a
hippie commune somewhere in ireland then
another said that the horse had been
stolen by the new orleans mafia or given
to the libyan leader muammar gaddafi the
madness went on for a few months before
the public started getting bored and the
media began looking for the next story
to grab their attention at that point
the affair was considered clothed
lloyd's of london the insurance company
paid out millions to the syndicate and
the shareholders were resigned to the
fact that sherga was probably dead and
they'd never see him again everyone
involved was ready to move on with their
lives but this still left the lingering
mystery of who kidnapped sharga what did
they do with him at first there was a
wide range of suspects including a rival
horse breeder who was an enemy of vega
khan however as the years passed all
fingers seemed to point in one direction
the irish republican army or ira
specifically it was the provisional ira
the paramilitary group responsible for
many of the violent events during the
30-year conflict known as the troubles
during the early 1980s they were hurting
for money and they'd kidnapped people
for ransom before so why not a horse
this is the version accepted by the
syndicate and the police although no
arrests were ever made the ira itself
never claimed responsibility but several
informants painted the picture of what
had happened the first was shauna
callahan who published his memoir on his
time with the ira in 1998. he claimed
that sugar had been killed less than 24
hours after being abducted because the
kidnappers didn't think to bring along
someone who was actually trained and
equipped to deal with a horse
surprisingly enough the machine gun
threat didn't work as well on animals as
they did on humans and sherga injured
himself after thrashing about in his
trailer this confirmed the suspicions of
the syndicate all those years ago that
the polaroids of sherga were all
headshots because the horse was already
dead at that point a different informant
who claimed to have witnessed the event
gave a much more brutal and violent
description of sherga's final moments
sherga was machine gun to death there
was blood everywhere and the horse even
slipped on its own blood there was lots
of cussing and swearing because the
horse wouldn't die it was a very bloody
death and that was possibly the brutal
end of shergar and it's the end of
today's video do you hope you enjoyed it
if you did please like below and thank
you for watching
you